peter i want to get right to it because
you had so much great stuff in monday's
football morning in america looking back
at the draft a lot of the movement in
round one a lot of the decisions made in
round one and i want to start at the top
the pick that the cardinals tried to
keep as secret for as long as they
possibly could we all knew they were
taking kyler murray but it's still a
fascinating story that when you take
josh rosen at number 10 last year trade
up to get josh rosen you're done with
him after one year and you go with kyler
murray
uh what what did you learn speaking to
gm steve kim and coach cliff kingsbury
about that decision to go franchise
quarterback one year after kyme tried to
go franchise quarterback
you know i think you know kyme still
insists mike to this day that he would
have kept josh rosen
but josh rosen knew what was gonna
happen uh and he knew it a day before
the draft he was walking through the
cardinals practice facility
you know because he was there every day
he was walking through the cardinals
practice facility he passed michael
bidwill in the hallway
and michael bidwell according to rosen
would not look at him
and so
you know he he basically said well i
know what's going on now right they're
gonna they're gonna pick kyler murray
and they're gonna trade me
but i think the interesting part about
the trade mike is
until the arizona cardinals
really got down to what i call nut cut
in time
late in the uh you know after they
picked kyler murray they did not engage
the miami dolphins and general manager
chris greer until after they made the
pick
and i believe part of that is due to the
fact that they were trying to keep
everything such a secret for so long
part of that is because the nfl wanted a
tv show part of it is because
they knew that the value
uh for kylo murray or for for josh rosen
was going to plummet
as soon as they let it be known out in
the world that they were trying to trade
him so to me
steve kind was in a virtually a no-win
situation
and i i don't think he did bad in
getting a 5 in 2020 and the 62nd pick
here but as i said in my story mike
imagine the pressure
on this receiver andy isabella
you know basically being the guy
who uh cost the arizona cardinals last
year three draft choices and then this
year
obviously they have to trade rosen and
so they got to use the 60 second pick in
the draft on this umass slot receiver i
mean you know he better catch about 138
balls this year to make it worth the
arizona cardinals while well peter this
is a one you know where i'm interested
in in this scenario i mean they take
kylie murray at one we knew cliff
kingsbury had a love affair with kyler
murray or at least we thought so you
know how much influence do you think
kingsbury had in this conversation and
ultimately drafting kyler murray
well kingsbury clearly wanted kyler
murray and he voiced that to steve kym
and michael bidwell
but according to both bidwell and are
according to both kyme and kingsbury
uh he
kingsbury never uh became
uh either annoying or demanding
about this and i asked him point blank
what if steve kimes says to you
hey listen
we think you can make josh rosen better
and we're going to take whoever quinn
and williams nick bosa
uh and he would have said and and and
kingsbury looked at me and he goes i
would have told them
uh basically let's go to work
i don't have any juice to come in and
demand who we make the first pick in the
draft
you know and it goes without saying he's
five under 500 at texas tech right you
know he gets fired last year mid-season
at texas tech so
i think he was adamant with me he said
he never said at the scouting combine
that it was a done deal that they were
taking
um
kyler murray so look
i know what everybody in the football
world thinks everybody thinks that the
fix was in
for kyler murray the day that uh cliff
kingsbury got hired the general manager
in kingsbury himself adamantly denied
that to me
but here's the thing peter and this was
a great point you made about the
cardinals keeping their cards so close
to the vest for as long as they did to
the point where it undermined their
ability to maximize their value for josh
rosen because they didn't even begin to
try in earnest to trade him until after
they took color murray and the value was
beginning to plummet i used to always
love the paul harvey and now you know
the rest of the story i think there's
the rest of the story here on the back
end i think the cardinals got something
whether it's another super bowl whether
it's they got something from the league
for keeping their mouths shut and not
trying to trade josh rosen when they
could have traded him in march they
could have traded him before the start
of the offseason program they could have
put him on the market but it would have
been clear the moment they did that kyle
murray is their guy and who cares if
everyone knows kyle murray is their guy
they run the board with the first
overall pick i just want to know what
the quid pro quo was here for the
cardinals to undermine their strategic
interests and keep their mouths shut
beyond the point where they could have
gotten more for josh rosen
i mean we'll find out over time did the
did the uh
sa at the time the st louis rams did
they get anything for
the favor
of drafting michael sam late in the
seventh round instead of michael sam
being a free agent if so i don't know
what it is uh and it might they're in
l.a they got they got they got the la
stadium deal when the charges and the
raiders were had the competing project
in carson so i think it worked out
pretty well for the rams to play ball
with the golf i mean mike hey mike mike
if you think agreeing to draft michael
sam 250th overall
uh was traded for the ability to move to
la and get that stadium you're out of
your mind every little thing is out of
his mind we know
well we know that when you're trying to
move to la every little bit helps
yeah yeah but but i you know mike i'll
just say i'll say one thing about about
this whole thing because somebody out in
arizona on saturday you know after i had
uh finished with kyme and kingsbury said
well okay what would you have done you
know if you were steve kaim
and i said here's exactly what i would
have done
i would have called the miami dolphins
the new york giants and i would have
called washington's bruce allen and i
would have said about an hour before the
draft
and i would have said to all of them
okay
make me your best offer one hour from
now for josh rosen and whoever whoever's
whoever gives me the best offer we're
you know we're parceling this out
whoever wants to make an offer for josh
rosen give me your best offer
because at that point
okay so maybe
maybe
you know the secret gets out then but at
least
you're now competing because i know mike
the new york giants had some interest in
josh rosen would it have been enough
for them to not draft
daniel jones i don't know the answer to
that but i do know the giants had some
interest obviously miami had some
interest and i don't really know about
washington but i think that that would
have given them the chance by the time
it's
after their pick the giants are already
locked and loaded on daniel jones and i
think then it's a one team market you
got dan snyder he wants haskins by then
i don't know if it would have changed
right but i think it would have given
him at least a better chance yeah okay
here's another thing i'm fascinated by
this just because i feel like it's rare
maybe you don't have the answer to this
peter but you usually have answers to a
lot of things because i know you know a
lot of people you know usually with the
first pick of the draft we hear about
other teams who are hot on the guy as
well i thought it was very weird this
year where we didn't hear about teams
who also were in love with kyler murray
uh i'm just interested and again like
maybe you don't know but if if arizona
doesn't take kyler murray what other
teams did you know or hear out there
that might have been interested in them
chris i think that is an excellent point
although steve kime spent about 10
minutes with me and i i didn't write
this but he spent a good deal of time
with me
telling me his calls around the league
in the last couple of months and talking
to his peers
these guys just loved kyler murray and
i'm not saying that they didn't right
there's a difference between loving them
and maybe picking them yeah whereas a
year ago chris do you remember a year
ago peter schrager reported this on the
night of the draft a year ago that josh
mcdaniels the offensive coordinator of
the patriots spent monday before the
draft with baker mayfield in his home in
austin texas right and and so the
patriots really were interested in in in
baker mayfield and if he had dropped
down if he was seven eight nine ten and
baker mafia was still on the board i
believe to this day the patriots would
have aggressively gone after baker
mayfield last year and tried to trade up
to get him but the fact is this year i
mean i i don't know this but it sure
doesn't sound like the patriots liked
anybody any of these top quarterbacks
and certainly not kyler murray right um
and and i think though i think
this was a case that some of the teams
that truly loved kyler murray
like john gruden i really love kyler
murray like shawn mcveigh who really
loved kyler murray
they were not in a position to to either
draft or trade to get in position to
take kyler murray right now what would
have happened if the cardinals passed on
him i i don't know what would have
happened but he might have gone into a
free fall i just don't know yeah
yeah i was told friday that it quite
possibly would have been him instead of
dwayne haskins to washington at 15. if
if he gets past john gruden at number
four that would have been the key right
getting past gruden there and then you
have to factor in the possibility that
somebody would try to cut the line in
front of washington because it would
have been obvious they'd have interest
in him if he's available at number 15.
so somebody jumps up to number 14 to try
to get him that way but but you know
just like because
peter i firmly believe that if kyle
murray had decided to play baseball
dwayne haskins is the guy we would have
been talking about before the draft as
the best quarterback the best prospect
the best potential franchise player but
kyle murray sucked all the oxygen out of
the room once he decided to play uh
football instead of baseball and uh you
know
maybe uh maybe that's ultimately what
would have occurred we would have had
haskins go to arizona and uh who knows
what would have happened after that
we've lost peter temporarily we'll try
to get him back this may be a good spot
to take a break yeah it's about that
time let's take a quick break here and
we'll try to get peter back and when we
return we will be talking about
john elway and the
strong feelings he has for joe flacco
even though he drafted drew locke in
round two on friday more pft library
after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports